for the last 19 years Cartman has been
bigoted and Kenny has died but how did
all that start in 1992 Matt Stone and
Trey Parker were in college at the
University of Colorado
they made a four-minute film called the
spirit of Christmas the film shows four
boys three of whom resemble the current
Kenny Cartman and Stan oh no here--like
the boys put a magic hat on a snowman
who then comes alive grows octopus
tentacles and kills Kenny
but Kenny looks like Cartman the octo
snowman
now disguised as Santa Claus also kills
the kid who looks like Kenny the
remaining two boys wake up baby Jesus
from a nearby nativity scene and Jesus
defeats frosty using his halo like a
boomerang normal a second short also
called the spirit of Christmas was
released by Matt Stone and Trey Parker
three years later showing a more modern
South Park cast Jesus now grown and
Santa Claus get into a fighting game
style battle with Highlander overtones
the five minute film features the show's
first references to Brian Boitano
someone say my name Kyle and Cartman
discussing weighty issues like carbon
being fat also Kenny being eaten by rats
both films and with a moral though
Christmas is all about presents this
second short gained popularity from word
of mouth and VHS copies spread
throughout the US finally getting the
attention of the budding cable network
Comedy Central Matt Stone and Trey
Parker went on to make a 22 minute pilot
for the network called Cartman gets an
anal probe